today's video has been made possible by
the great courses plus
an on-demand video learning service that
gives you access to some of the best
courses lectures and documentaries on a
vast array of subjects
stick around until the end to find out
more about today's great offer
my first experience with the book of
enoch was about three years ago when i
first started making videos on greek
mythology
a comment that i'd see all the time was
one telling me that the greek deities
were in fact
fallen angels and their children were
nephilim
this obviously made no sense to me
because it isn't something ever
mentioned or alluded to in greek
myth it also didn't help that the people
i saw quoting the book of enoch did so
in the same incoherent manner
so it came across as not much more than
gibberish for
lack of a better term the blabbering of
a crazy person who had just joined some
weird new age cult is what i assumed i
was reading
eventually i was curious enough to do
some of my own further reading into this
mysterious book
and what i found was at the very least
interesting the book of enoch is
essentially an ancient hebrew religious
text
ascribed to enoch the great grandfather
of
noah it's made up of several shorter
books that discuss
the origins of giants and demons
how the angels fell from grace and why
the great flood of genesis was necessary
despite the notion that the book of
enoch helped form the world view of
judaism and
christianity neither recognized it as
biblical canon
it is referenced but never considered a
work inspired by god
others interpret this to mean the book
of enoch was removed from the bible
because it challenged beliefs and
inspired ideas the church had deemed as
dangerous
now as to which one of these is true i'm
sure it will be
argued for thousands and thousands of
years to come
in this video i'd like to take a look at
the first book which focuses on the fall
of the watchers
the angelic figures who betrayed god and
created the nephilim
the first book in the book of enoch is
known as the book of the watchers
you can pretty much read these in
whatever order you desire
the book of the watchers begins with
enoch being described
as a righteous man who has journeyed to
the heavens and had his eyes opened by
god
it then mentions a future where god
shall come forth and tread upon the
earth
all shall tremble in fear and the
watchers shall quake
this is referring to judgment day all
that is wicked on the earth shall perish
except for the righteous who will be
granted mercy
and given god's blessing the first few
things we can take from this
is that the watchers were mentioned
separately from men
meaning they are more than human they
also have a reason to fear the judgment
of
god it then goes on to say god shall
bring with him ten thousand of his holy
ones to assist
in this judgment some interpret this to
mean an
army of ten thousand angels and others
simply believe this
refers to the judges of morality
the first five chapters discuss this
judgment in some more detail
but it's chapter number six where we
begin to hear about the story of the
watchers
so what exactly are they as their name
would suggest
the watchers were tasked with watching
over humanity and the earth
they saw and heard everything they were
the messengers and middle ground
between the earth and heaven everything
that happened on earth was seen
and ordained by the watchers on behalf
of god
given that description it's not
unreasonable to say the watchers must
have been
angels but they aren't described amongst
god's most
trusted angels enoch himself does refer
to them as angels and states that there
were 200 watchers
with only their leaders being named so
it's fair to say
the watchers may have been lesser angels
or some kind of holy being unknown to
humanity
the conflict in this story begins when
the watchers abandoned their duties
they watched over the children of men
for years as they multiplied
and became obsessed with the beauty of
their daughters
eventually they decided it was time to
descend upon the earth
and take mortal wives to bear their
children
the leader of the watchers samiaza
feared not all would agree with this
idea
and the punishment for such a sin would
fall solely on him
the ten chiefs of the watchers all took
an oath that meant they couldn't abandon
this plan
the oath also bound them to one another
meaning any
punishment would fall upon all of them
and so they abandoned their post and
descended upon the earth
taking mortal wives the chief watchers
shared knowledge and secrets which were
forbidden
teaching humanity all sorts of
enchantments and charms
the children from this union between
watcher and human
were known as nephilim giants who were
over
four thousand feet tall the nephilim
were savage beings who man could not
control
eventually the giants turned on them
roaming the land
pillaging and destroying everything in
their path
a watcher known as azazel taught humans
how to make
weapons and armor and with this
discovery came
untold bloodshed amongst humanity
enoch also describes the teaching of
beautifying
eyelids and costly stones tamiya knew
that just means the watchers showed
women what
makeup and jewelry was and as a result
they were more attractive to men
long story short the watchers came to
earth and had some crazy giant children
shared some divine secrets and
encouraged behavior that was
previously seen as taboo
the archangels michael uriel
raphael and gabriel observe this lawless
and unrighteous behavior taking place
and decide they must act they turn to
god who tells them
he is aware of the situation and he has
a plan
this plan just happens to be the end of
days
the only way to ensure the nephilim do
not continue to breed
and destroy humanity is to destroy
everything and start again
each one of the archangels is given a
task of
paramount importance uriel is sent to
make sure noah
is aware of this plan so he can prepare
and survive
as the task of repopulating the earth
will fall upon him
raphael is sent to punish azazel to bind
him
and cast him into darkness to be
specific he is asked to make an
opening in the desert and throw azazel
in there
cover him in jagged rock so he may never
see the light again
until the end of days when he is to be
thrown into the fire
which will heal the earth of all the sin
and corruption as asel calls with the
secrets he chose to share
gabriel is given the task of destroying
the children of the watchers
as well as the children of men born from
sin
he does so by inciting a great battle
between the two
lastly michael was told to bind the
leader of the watchers samyaza
along with all the other watchers who
defiled themselves in unions with
mortals
they were to be bound in the valleys of
the earth for 70 generations
until the day of judgment
12 onwards explains enoch's
participation in all of this
it states that he was hidden from the
children of men who had no idea what had
happened to him
his time away was spent with the
watchers and the holy ones
it was now his responsibility to mediate
between the watchers
and those in heaven enoch tells the
watchers of god's plan
and they beg and plead with him to draw
up a petition
trembling in fear they now seek
forgiveness for their actions
when enoch falls asleep he has a dream
with god's response
the petition is denied the watchers
would not receive forgiveness
nor would they ever ascend to heaven
again the petition on behalf of their
children would
also be denied they would have to watch
as the nephilim were killed
right before them enoch continues to
explain his dream describing the palaces
of heaven
and the reasons why the watchers shall
never receive redemption
the watchers were blessed to live for
eternity but they defiled themselves
with the flesh
and blood of mortals when the children
of men were created
they lusted for blood and flesh and so
they were given wives
the angels were not meant to share these
desires and so
they had no need for wives enoch then
discusses a journey through shield
a dark place with a dead go a sought
over underworld
in this dark fiery abyss yurio tells him
this is the prison for the watchers
the angels who dared to rebel against
god and corrupt
mankind that is the fate they are
destined to serve for eternity
and nothing they do will ever change
this fate
the story of the watchers and even the
name itself
appears in several other texts such as
the second book of enoch
and the book of giants one of the most
noticeable references was in genesis
where you have the same story but
instead of the watchers the
angels are referred to as the sons of
god
the sons of god saw how beautiful the
daughters of man had become
and took them as wives however this time
their offspring were celebrated as
heroes and not demonized as
monsters the rest of the book of enoch
does mention the archangels in some more
detail
and maybe we'll cover them along with
the nephilim in separate videos
let me know if that's something you'd
like to see
as we mentioned at the start of the
video it's sponsors like the great
courses plus that make this content
possible
i'm sure at this point we're all pretty
used to on-demand subscription services
netflix disney plus and so on the great
courses plus is fairly similar but
instead of feeling bad after binging 12
hours of an awful tv show out of boredom
you can be productive and learn
something new there is a vast catalogue
of lectures
courses and documentaries taught by ivy
league professors and other fascinating
individuals
the topics range from finance fitness
food and travel
to history philosophy science and
literature
so there should be something there to
tickle everyone's fancy
you can stream the great courses plus
from your tv tablet
laptop or phone whichever you prefer
if it's about space or dinosaurs then
i'm normally interested
but the great courses plus does give me
an extra resource when it comes to
researching video ideas and coming up
with new topics
if you enjoyed learning about the book
of enoch then there is an entire section
devoted just to ancient religion
i'd recommend a pagan world but there
are dozens more to
choose from if that sounds good you can
start your free trial today
by visiting thegreatcoursesplus.com
mythology or by simply clicking on the
link in the description
so give it a try and let me know if you
learn anything particularly interesting
as always i've been your host mythology
and fiction explained
[Music]
[Music]
you